[Applaudissements]
bonjour juste bienvenus non non pas de l
installe toi tu es chez toi atteint
maire de trois-bassins chier et rap
associés alors je te dire quelque chose
j'ai du coca de l'eau du rhône jambes
non non juste un verre d'eau à bordeaux
tu es sage j'aime bien moi je me prends
un petit saint jean
ça doit aller aux petites gens j'aime
beaucoup
justin j'ai vu la vidéo
oui oui j'ai vu ta vidéo 3 millions de
vues c'est vraiment fort et je veux pas
passé par quatre chemins justice
je vais te signé un contrat exclusif
avec international des normes sepa
justin en commun c'est plutôt le bon
dieu est abandonné toutes ses qualités
ça te dérange pas enlève ses chaussures
justice non non pas du tout c'est juste
une chatte à dire tu es un potentiel
incroyable
non vraiment je te le dis tu es un
potentiel incroyable pour moi que la
future beyoncé mais en fait moi je suis
très influencé par des chanteuses un peu
guitare voix comme christy chapman et je
chante principalement foncé ouais donc
potentiels mondial je sais pas trop si
on jouait tous justin tu tu es dans une
humilité et ça c'est tout à ton honneur
vraiment pour moi j'ai travaillé depuis
plus de 10 ans dans ce métier j'ai
travaillé avec lara fabian c'est l'idiot
brigitte fossey et était comme tout au
début tout préserver le petit bout de
femme comme ça que timide peu comme ça
péter mondialement s était à la hauteur
et c'est ça que j'attends que toi
certain du tout que tu te donnes à fond
de cale à fond dans ce nouveau challenge
et tu peux le faire parce que je vais te
dire qu'un cochon disque tu m'appelles
prime c'est la facom dit ça c'est vrai
pourquoi mais moi je suis le premier de
stabiliser le patient quand je t'entends
dont tu peux chanter un peu là pouvoir
semble tu me manques
mon amour je te manque
mon ami
pour et si on partait en voyage c'est
mon ami ça te dérange pas je n'ai
franchement pas faire de grandes choses
en somme c'est sûr
j'ai hâte à dieu du style il ya quand
même tic dans ton projet j'écoutais
vraiment et production musicale
elles sont nuls à chier tu es tu ta
qualité c'est la voix donc il te faut
quelque chose à la hauteur de ta voix tu
composes revenir et passer commande pour
moi donc je fais quelque chose le
meilleur ou toi donc la banque est bien
dissiper le problème un faux pas du tout
inquiétés j'ai ma petite idée jeu
j'ai un ami qui lui qui alors farrell
pharrell williams le leader du groupe
nerd l'auteur de happy yes encore au bac
akon ou bac pharrell williams hockey qui
disparaît quissac et support il a déjà
raconté se voir ce que vous faites
toujours des blagues
il a poussé michael fuchs a su c'est mon
frère d'une autre mer rouge la danse
cela donne ça te dérange pas j'enlève
mon portable pour faire de grandes
choses ensemble justin
justin tu sais ce passé un truc tu as
des problèmes en beauté du christian
diot a dénoncé ces malades préfèrent
d'accord c'est bien de le savoir
maintenant parce que comme ça je peux
anticiper
parce que je pensais à quelque chose là
tu sais qu'ils cherchent une nouvelle
égérie en ce moment chez nous c'est déjà
parce que beau maillot koutiala
totalement petit dodo de vue de la fée
batman madame cnt complique avec et puis
rihanna lance moment c'est n'importe
quoi mais je ne parle plus ça reste
entre nous tu lui dis pas mais je suis
très en colère contre elle m'a fait un
sale coup je te dire mot juste et de la
vie j'ai des principes je quelqu'un de
loyal
j'aime pas les micmacs une petite roule
avec moi on se parle on pourra voir des
hauts des bas c'est pas grave c'est la
vie mais c'est un dérange pas de
m'accompagner dans la salle de bain on
va y aller tu me suis totalement m
qu'est-ce qu'on allait promettant dans
ce genre d'appartements le faire de
cristal justice
approche n'ai pas peur je vais pas fait
une telle découverte depuis michel
sardou des wagons a explosé dans tous
les sens sont page pour riches
dis moi ça dérange pas me mettre un
petit peu de crème sur le dos avec la
viola ça m'a totalement asséché la peau
selon rim s'il allait un peu je veux
coquine mois les maintenant à des
conneries là dans les tropiques un qui
se passent très difficiles et juge la
technique et des gogos bois qu'est ce
que vous avez à dire sur ses talons de
12 mois je ne reconnais pas elle est
venue
je crois que tu te payes nom de dieu de
merde
attendez attendez donc pas à condamner
au meilleur
[Applaudissements]